[MUSIC PLAYING]
KYLE STORY: All right.
Today we're going to be
telling you a little bit
about understanding the earth,
machine learning, and then
a relatively new rule tool
called Kubeflow Pipelines.
I'm Kyle Story, a
computer vision engineer
and Descartes Labs.
And my co-presenter--
FAUSTINE LI: Hi.
I'm Faustine Li.
I'm also a computer
vision engineer.
KYLE STORY: And with
that, let's get started.
So we're going to run through a
lot of things during this talk.
The three key points that we
hope that you can walk away
from this room remembering
are that in the domain
that we work in,
satellite imagery,
there is an incredibly large
amount and a growing amount
of satellite imagery.
And it provides a
very powerful way
of understanding
the world around us.
Second, machine learning is
a very powerful technique
for processing and understanding
the satellite imagery.
But it presents unique
challenges in this domain.
And third, we are
using an array of tools
within the Google
Cloud suite to be
able to understand
these imagery,
provide value for our customers.
And in particular, we've been
exploring Kubeflow Pipelines,
so we'd like to tell you a
little bit about that today.
So what do you think of
when you think of the Earth?
What do you picture?
Perhaps it's this iconic
picture from the Apollo space
mission of almost 50
years ago, at this point,
a blue dot out in space.
Well, since that time technology
has allowed satellites
to take an increasingly
large amount of data covering
our globe through a wide
variety of spectrums,
and over a regular
time interval.
And what Descartes Labs--
we're in the business of taking
that massive amount of data,
using the Google
Cloud as a backbone,
and processing that into
valuable information
and decisions that our
customers can make.
So just to give
you a sense of what
we can do with
satellite imagery,
for example, in this
picture on the left hand
we've used a particular
combination of spectral bands
that pull out vegetation, allow
us to understand crops, crop
development.
In the center, this
synthetic aperture radar band
allows us to understand
built infrastructure
for mines and minerals further
to the right, and finally high
resolution satellite
imagery, allowing
us to study and understand,
in this case, oil
and gas infrastructure.
These are fracking
installations.
Outside of active sensors
in the visible bands,
they're are all--
sorry, passive sensors.
There are also active sensors.
For example, here is
synthetic aperture radar.
So this is actually
a satellite that's
flying over, sending
down a radar signal,
receiving the reflected signal.
And so that allows us to
both see the reflections off
of metal structures or you
can see all the boats flowing
into this harbor, and also
learn about 3D information
in this picture.
That all is to say that there
is an incredible amount of data
that's being produced all
the time from satellites
and other sources.
That data gives us a
really valuable picture
for understanding
the world around us
and deriving actual insights.
This is a picture that was
taken by the Sentinel satellite
shortly after the Camp fire
erupted in northern California
in November.
You can see the plumes of
smoke coming off of the place
where the fire is burning.
And by looking into different
spectral wavelengths
than our eye can
see, we can actually
pick out where the fire
is actively burning.
This is a shortwave infrared
and a near infrared false color
image.
We can see where the fires act
is actually actively burning,
in this case.
And so by using
satellite imagery,
that allows us to
really understand
what's going on in our world
in a very powerful way.
What's important then is turning
that massive amount of data
into decisions or understanding
that our customers can use.
So here is an image
of crop fields
over in the center of the
United States, in Nebraska.
And we've built
out a pipeline that
allows us to predict the
amount of corn and soy
that are produced in a
given growing season.
And then that helps our
customers, in particular cargo,
be able to understand how
they move grain around,
and then what they
can expect for prices
in the agricultural market.
As I mentioned
earlier on, we find
that computer vision and machine
learning is a very powerful way
of understanding these data
sets and being able to produce
insights at scale.
And that's what the
remainder of this talk
will largely focus on.
So within satellite imagery
and computer vision,
we think about these
along three axes--
detect, map, and monitor.
So detect is using
computer vision machine
learning to be able to
find infrastructure, find
the points of interest,
the things that you're
interested in all
around the globe,
mapping those across,
so mapping those
across the globe in the
different regions of interest
that you're interested in.
And then finally, being able
to monitor those in real time,
being able to
understand changes,
and then use that to
drive your business.
So for an example
of detection we've
built a computer
vision algorithm
that can detect wind turbines.
And we can now run this
anywhere in the world.
We're able to use
Google Cloud to map
all of the wind turbines in
the United States over night.
Mapping-- so this is a
convolutional neural net that
maps out the
footprints of buildings
in high resolution
satellite imagery.
You can see the
satellite imagery
on the left, and then the output
of this neural net algorithm
in the middle and on the right.
And then finally,
monitoring change over time.
So this is a pixel-based
random forest algorithm
that uses the spectral
information from the Sentinel
satellite to be able
to make a mask of where
water is at any time.
And what you're
seeing here is running
that over sequential time
slices of satellite imagery.
And you're seeing this
reservoir in northern California
dry up during the drought
of the previous few years.
So with that, I'd
like to hand over
the rest of the presentations
to my co-presenter, Faustine,
to dig into all the things
that I've been presenting
in a little more detail.
FAUSTINE LI: Thanks, Kyle.
So I want to preface
my part of the talk
by saying we're not
really all that interested
in digging into the
algorithms behind our models.
If you're interested in
domain-specific algorithms,
Kyle gave a great talk
at last year's NeXT.
But for this talk, what
we found as scientists
was that we really couldn't
treat the model as a black box,
even though we really wanted to.
That data goes in
and answers come out.
Well, what happens to
the data and how does it
arrive in our model?
And what do we do
with the outputs?
Where do we store
it, and so forth?
So what we found was that we
should focus on our workflows
and how to streamline those.
So let me step through this.
So there's a lot of things that
happen after the imagery comes
off of the satellite.
We have a great ingest team that
ingests data into our platform
that we built on
top of Google Cloud.
But, of course, imagery
is completely useless
if we can't access it.
So we host microservices
that allow scientists
to programmatically
query and access imagery.
And we interact with
those microservices
using our Descartes
Labs Python Library.
Once we have training data,
it's time to train our model.
And we build convolutional
neural networks in TensorFlow.
And we heavily leverage
Google Compute Engine
to train our models.
And we found that deep
learning VMs are really
fast to get us started.
But, of course, now that
we're ready with our model
it's time to deploy.
And for large
geospatial applications,
that often means inference over
multiple regions of interest.
And we actually have a task
system that we built and host.
And that allows us to
scale out our models
by 100 or 1,000 times.
And I'll talk a little bit
more about this in depth later.
So to dive in a
little bit deeper,
I don't want to
belabor the point.
But our imagery is
not just pixels.
In fact, it has a lot of
Earth science related to it.
And so prior to
analysis, we have
to georegister and co-locate
all of our imagery.
And we also have to
care about things
like atmospheric reflectants
or whether clouds are obscuring
our objects of interest.
Once our imagery is analytics
ready, we have to access it.
And because our
data platform holds
large, multi-modal data
sets, we have APIs that
make it really easy to access.
So in four lines of Python code
we get imagery over New Mexico,
almost instantaneously.
And this is really
great for developers.
Because it means that
if I want imagery
over a different satellite, I
just change one line of code.
But deployment is
where it gets tricky.
Often we might want
every square kilometer
of a very large
region of interest,
like the United States.
So how do we do this?
We have a task
system that we built
that allows us to scale these
highly elastic workflows.
And the way we do it
is we have a client
that creates tiles over the
earth of arbitrary size,
and each tile has a
hash associated with it.
We have a deployment
script that knows
how to instantiate a model, how
to predict, how to pre-process
and post-process that data.
And we feed it into
our task's API,
and that all runs in Kubernetes.
So the Earth is
massively paralyzable.
All you have to do is chip it
into non-overlapping tiles,
and each tile goes into a
separate Docker container.
And this leverages all
the really nice things
about Kubernetes, like auto
scaling, CPU and GPU node
pulls, things like that.
But we want our results back.
And so we host a catalog API.
We're populating those APIs,
that REST endpoint as we go,
asynchronously.
So at the end, you get a map of
the Earth with your inference
on top of it.
So why are we using Kubeflow?
Well, conceptually
machine learning pipelines
are pretty straightforward.
We get data.
We train a model.
And then we deploy.
But we found that really,
that's not the case.
And research projects become
quickly unmaintainable.
And I didn't really talk
about model training,
because it's probably the
least inspiring part of what
we do as scientists.
Currently we sort of manage
our VM infrastructure.
We have to manage our own GPUs.
We have to make sure that
Kuta is properly installed.
and so on.
And we spend a lot of time
debugging things like this
instead of focusing
on the science.
And that's what we really want.
And this is a really awesome
thing, this task system.
But the deploy script is
pretty monolithic and hard
to maintain.
And we really want
to be able to have
componentized our deployments.
So with those pain
points and many more--
for example, we had
difficulties with managing
the training environment versus
the deployment environment.
And we had ran into hard
to debug bugs with that.
Kubeflow Pipelines seemed
like a great option for us.
It was immediately attractive,
because the main points
of Kubeflow are things
that we are running into
and we want to solve internally.
So what is Kubeflow Pipelines?
It is a machine
learning workflow that--
a machine learning system
that manages machine learning
workflows on Kubernetes.
And it aims to make
machine learning
reusable and reproducible,
and takes a machine
learning product all the
way from experimentation
to deployment.
And, of course, it runs natively
on Kubernetes, which is great.
Because all of
our infrastructure
runs on the cloud,
on Kubernetes,
and it works really
well with our APIs.
So specifically
about Pipelines--
the core unit of
work in Pipelines
is a operation or component.
And they all run in
a Docker container.
And each component has
an output and input,
and we do graph inference.
So it's a directic
acyclic graph of work,
and it leverages all
the wonderful things
about Kubernetes, like
auto scaling, like metrics,
and so on.
So this is kind of what
a Pipeline looks like.
It's basically a Python
function with operations inside.
And we know that
this is a Pipeline
because we add a
little decorator that
says DSL Pipeline.
And all this Pipeline does
is it downloads a text
file from a Google
bucket and prints it out.
And I'll show you this
later in the demo.
It says Hello, Google Next.
OK.
So here's the fun part.
I wrote a end to end machine
learning Pipeline in Kubeflow.
And I'm going to
demo it really soon.
But the application will be
detecting oil and gas sites
in the Permian Basin.
These are what they look like.
They're called well pads.
If you don't know
what a well pad is,
it's basically a large
concrete rectangle
that they put equipment
on while they're
drilling for oil and gas.
And we might be
interested in looking
for these because we might be
interested in monitoring where
fracking activity
is, or by seeing
where they're being built
we can monitor our energy
infrastructure.
So we want to turn
this into this.
So how do we do that?
Well, thankfully, I wrote a end
to end Pipeline in Kubeflow.
So it goes from pulling the
imagery from our platform
from just simple labels, to
deploying on our task system
and seeing the output.
OK.
So when the demo
is running, you'll
be able to see that this
Pipeline does both training
and deployment.
And there's some things that
we really like about Pipelines.
So, for example, each component
friends its own Docker
container, which means that we
can encapsulate the environment
that we're working on it.
And we really can control
the very specific packages
that we put in it.
So we can make sure that
our training and deployment
environments always match.
And because each component
is containerized,
we can mix and match components.
So it promotes reuse.
And there's some neat
things about Pipelines
that I hope to show you.
So they have native
TensorBoard integration,
which is really great.
Because you can inspect how
your model's performing,
and you can compare
different runs.
So it really supports
the experimentation side
of model building.
And there's some great things
about deploying with Pipelines.
So it leverages all the
Kubernetes infrastructure
that we have in-house.
It interopts well with
the tools that we use.
So we heavily use Stackdriver
and ISTIO, and Spinnaker.
So all those things
work with Kubeflow.
And managing identities
and different workflows
with different
scientists is really
easy with Kubernetes or
Google Cloud and Kubernetes
authentication.
And I didn't really
mention this.
This is not the
focus of this talk.
But what we really
found great was
that Kubeflow Pipelines are a
first class citizen and a AI
hub.
And it's a problem internally
where we onboard new scientists
and we want to get
them up to speed.
And how do we do that?
Well, previously we had to
point them to a GitHub repo
and say install these
packages, run this code.
And it's really awesome
to be able to point
to somebody in AI hub and
say download this pipeline.
Run it in this cluster.
And it's very, very
straightforward now.
OK.
Well, I guess I will close
off this talk, the demo is not
working, and contextualize what
we're trying to do in the--
oh, well, the demo is working.
[LAUGHS] So I will
actually show you this.
Because this is really awesome.
OK.
So this is the UI for
Kubeflow Pipelines.
And this is that Hello
World Pipeline that I just
showed you from before.
And it's as easy
as clicking run.
So let's call this run Hello.
We'll click Start.
It takes a couple seconds for
Kubernetes to schedule some--
the pods.
But it should show up
very, very briefly.
There we go.
It's running.
Looks like that completed,
so let's refresh.
Hello, Google Cloud Next.
But, you know, that's not
really what we're here for.
We're here for machine
learning workflows.
And this is that
oil and well pads
demo I talked about earlier.
So it's basically just
as easy as the last one.
Let's call this Demo.
I can add a description.
I can add it to an experiment.
Let's not do that.
There's some parameters
that I can set on the fly.
And then I can click
Start, and it's on its way.
So the idea behind Kubeflow
is that machine learning
should be as--
machine learning should be
as painless as possible.
And previously, there
wasn't really great tools.
TensorFlow democratized
training models,
but really training is only a
small part of the whole machine
learning workflow and cycle.
In fact, train model
is just one operation
of this multi-step Pipeline.
All right.
So let's check on what
our model is doing.
There we go.
Awesome.
So these schemas basically
are JSON peramiter files
that tell each operation certain
characteristics about the data,
like which satellite
it should pull from,
what date range it should
look for, things like that.
And that's all we
provide to our Pipeline.
Right now it's actually
pulling imagery live
from our Descartes
Labs platform.
And you can see
it streaming now.
And this just goes to show
how fast our data access is.
If you were to try and
do geospatial analysis
20 years ago, you
would have to work
with these very bespoke and
oftentimes slow interfaces.
OK.
Well, training
image is completed.
It pushed it to a Google
bucket, so let's check that out.
Here we go.
So our V2 images
are in this bucket.
We can scroll around
and look at that.
So very briefly, the
machine learning algorithm
that we're using to train
our oil and well pad detector
is what we call
core segmentation.
So the input images
look like this.
So this is a well pad.
And the target images
look like this.
So it's a binary image,
where the well pads are.
And we notice that
it's much, much smaller
than the original target image.
And that's because for simple
shapes like these well pads,
you don't really need
that high fidelity.
And because the target
image is really small,
these models train much faster.
And you see you'll get
pretty good results
with a limited amount of data
and a limited amount of epochs
to train.
So let's check in
on our Pipeline.
It will update on the fly.
It looks like it's training
our model right now.
What we did was
we pulled imagery
down from what we've
created in previous steps.
And it looks like
it's on epoch four.
And the great thing
about Pipelines
is that this stuff is
training on the GPU.
And as long as we have
GDU nodes available,
Kubeflow will schedule them.
And what's really great is that
upgrading your GPUS to TPUs
is just as transparent as adding
TPU nodes to your node pools.
So this should be done
in a couple minutes.
We're on epoch seven.
So while that's training I
can show you very briefly
what our labels look like.
So this is our base
satellite imagery.
And these are our labels.
We don't have a
whole lot of them.
But we've found that
these core segmentation
models train pretty quickly.
And we can zoom in
on and take a look
at some of these well pads.
So this is 60 centimeter
imagery over NAP.
NAP is a from the National
Agricultural Program.
So a lot of this
imagery is obstensively
for agriculture research.
So I kind of zoomed
in on the well pad.
You can kind of see
there's a little dark spot
on the center of these.
That's where they put the
well when they put the pump
jack to pump the oil out.
OK.
So I think that our training
should be close to done.
Yeah.
It looks like it's
saving the model.
It takes a little
while to upload.
Good.
Here we go.
So let's take a look here.
And we can see that it saves
our model weights in the cloud.
And if we go back, we
can see that this metrics
panel is done.
So let's take a look at that.
And we can open up TensorBoard
right from Kubeflow Pipelines.
So that's great.
We see that our loss
went down over time.
And it just launched
our catalog end point.
That's where we store our data.
And now it's launching
our task system.
So this will do the
actual inference.
So our task takes a
little while to start up.
And that's just loading
a task controller,
making sure our deploy
script's in there, distributed
to the worker nodes.
And it takes a little bit
of time to spin up the--
to get the resources.
So we can see that our
tasks are pending now.
Once that's done, it should
start the inference job.
And it should be pretty fast.
Yeah.
So our TensorBoard logs
are available here.
If they're multiple
in one file, you
can compare the runs
and things like that.
OK.
So our task system
says it started.
And we can look at
our task monitor
and see that it
is indeed running.
So it's already scheduling
work on these nodes.
And look, we already
have 127 active workers.
And it's already succeeding.
So as soon as this is done,
we can look at the outputs.
And it's going
really, really fast.
[LAUGHS]
OK.
So that is completed.
And Kubeflow should think that
that's completed very soon.
All right.
Awesome.
So now this task,
this component is just
pulling down imagery
from our catalog product.
That's where we
deployed our model over,
and where we store our results.
And this should be
very quick, too.
And then once this is done, we
can look at our final results.
So yeah, this is
incredibly powerful.
We just took a computer
vision model from no data
to deployed in less
than 10 minutes.
And it's completely reproducible
with Kubeflow Pipelines.
All right.
Awesome.
This is done.
Another neat thing
about Kubeflow
is that you can embed
arbitrary HTML assets.
So here we go.
We can see a tile of what we
predicted, and the results.
So let's take a
look at our product.
And this is also in viewer.
And let me zoom
out a little bit.
OK.
So this is our deployed
computer vision model.
I can overlay the base
imagery, so let do that.
And then we can compare.
So it didn't train with
a whole lot of data,
and it didn't train with
a whole lot of epochs.
But it looks like it
did learn something.
And, you know, it's really
easy to start the loop
back over again, add more data,
retrain, try different models.
Because we've really
reduced that developer cycle
exponentially with
Kubeflow Pipelines.
Awesome.
So that was the demo.
We can go back to the slides.
Maybe.
OK.
So I want to wrap up this
talk and contextualize what
we're doing in the scale of
the science that we're doing.
And, of course, everybody
likes pretty pictures.
So these are projects that we've
actually deployed to scale.
So for example, this is all the
trees in New York City, mapped.
And if you're interested
in looking at trees,
this visualization was done by
our awesome creative marketing
guy, Tim Wallace.
He has a great "Medium"
article available.
And in principle, we can map all
the trees in the United States.
And, of course, this
is really useful.
Because we can monitor where
deforestation and reforestation
is happening.
For something a
little bit different,
this is a global N02 map.
So nitrogen dioxide is a
byproduct of combustion.
And so this map is
really telling us
where pollution is happening.
You can see hotspots of
where there's coal burning,
for example.
And the hotspot in
South Central Africa
is they do periodic
vegetation burning.
So this is something
that you normally
can't see with the naked
eye, but it becomes very
visible with certain sensors.
So polluters beware,
we can see you.
And this project shows some
of the turnaround and agility
that we have at Descartes Labs.
So these are
hundreds of thousands
of buildings over a
region in North Carolina.
And this was done overnight
ahead of Hurricane Florence,
so that we could sort of monitor
and predict how many buildings
were at risk.
Just to wrap up, we have
a lot of exciting science
at Descartes Labs,
mostly related
to the geospatial domain.
And Kubeflow Pipelines is
a great resource for us,
because it allows us
to handle the scale
and scope of our projects.
Kubeflow also works really
great with the tools we already
built on Google Cloud.
And it's becoming
better and better.
It's an open source project.
Everybody is free to support
and contribute to it.
And there's a lively
community already.
So here's a little bit
of information on how
to get started with Kubeflow.
And here's a little bit
of information about us.
Thank you for your
participation.
That's the end of our talk.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]